well I gotta tell you Constance so I saw
hustlers like last week we're not
allowed to talk about it
but it is a tweet saying guys I saw
hustlers
I've never gotten such a response like
DMS asked me how is it how is it like
people are dying to see you yeah like
are you overwhelmed by the anticipation
for this movie well I you know there's a
lot of anticipation for crazy imitations
true yeah so um kind of feels like I
know it's just really exciting that
people have interested and are excited
about it and the thing I feel like you
guys have like even like a poker game
you have an amazing hand that you're
just ready to show people like this is
an awesome movie like how does it feel
that people are gonna love this movie
it feels pretty good yeah I'm pretty
excited and I'm pretty I'm just proud of
all the girls and like excited to share
it with people because I think people
are gonna have a lot of fun but I also
think that I mean it was important to me
to build a lot of heart into this so
that you don't just judge women who are
strippers but you get to know them as
people and humans and I think we all
sort of did that with their own
characters and I think people are
responding to that too
yeah it's it's not like the one tweet I
got was they were saying is this gonna
be this generation showgirls when it's
not in any kind of way now yeah so let's
go you compared to the Goodfellas yeah
so it's like it's just completely gonna
change people's anticipations of what
this movie is right movie that
friendship and family yeah yeah now I
know you said you were intimidated to
take on this role was there anything
yeah I thought it went in DVD you said
you're a little bit intimidated at least
overwhelmed to take on no well I was
gonna say in terms of your other actors
in this movie they are seasoned
performers in terms of performing for an
audience or dancing on stages wizard
element day that was overall to be
around like j.lo and cardi B and Liz oh
and these kind of people that are more
used to performing for an audience it
was really inspiring actually I mean I
grew up doing theater so I'm used to
being on a stage and I don't know people
ask me about if I was like insecure
scared and I guess it's weird it's like
even if I am or was the second I get
into character it's like if that just
goes away cause it's like cuz I because
that that would be about me not about
destiny right so it's just it's it's a
weird thing that happens to me when I
act it's just sort of like oh okay we're
going in we're in right and so constants
--is insecurities get left at the door
because this isn't about her my job in
that moment is to do right by my
character right and and really portray
the integrity of her character and how
she feels about her body so I don't know
I just kind of dive in that's weird
well that's what being a really good
actress now I think people are gonna
talk about the scene with you and JLo in
the car jamming to Britney Spears oh
yeah yeah that was fun was that like a
choice that you guys made like how did
it come about that you chose that song
was that in the script and then we just
sort of played with it we just played
with improv iing and dancing and just
like wanted to be two great girls having
a great time yeah so much fun I'm so
excited for yeah the sequel the crazy
rotations
yeah it seems like big headline this
week with Adele Lim leaving the
production like the co-writer over money
like where's any kind of you had any
conversations about that like you're
involved in that in any way no cuz well
I'm not a producer on the film so I
didn't even know any of that stuff I
mean I know that I'm I'm signed on to do
two and three already yeah but but yeah
I didn't even know I don't they don't
tell me these things like were you
surprised to hear that no but uh I was
surprised to hear that because I know
her value as a writer I wasn't surprised
to hear it because I know how pay
disparity has traditionally been
throughout Hollywood history so while I
didn't know anything about it I think
it's good to have discussions about it
and and I think that Adele is a
wonderful writer and I think she
is I think she should be paid what she
is worth which is a lot especially to
all of us at grocery Jason's
congratulations on this movie I really
really love the honest it was like so
much fun watching this movie thanks I'm
glad you enjoyed you
you